so you're thinking of buying a Powerball
ticket oh you've already bought a few
well we've got some bad news you aren't
going to win almost certainly your
chances are one in 292 million you have
a better chance of being hit by
lightning which is nearly one in a
million that means you're almost 250
times more likely to get a bolt than a
winning ticket here's what those odds
come from all the different combinations
you can win by picking five white balls
in any order out of a drum of 69 then
you multiply that by 26 the number of
possible power balls your odds of
winning the 1.5 billion dollar jackpot
that's billion with a B are exactly the
same as they were in November when the
pot was a mere 40 million but the higher
the jackpot the more people will play
and the more likely the pot will be
split take out taxes and the grand prize
may be closer to half a billion dollars
so kiss those dreams of becoming an NBA
team owner goodbye or save your two
dollars and buy a doughnut the returns
are certain deliciousness doughnuts